.
* Kuckucksuhr *
James Odermatt ist
Betriebsleiter der Wiesenbergbahn.
James heisst eigentlich Hans.
Aber weil es in der Gegend
so viele Hans Odermatt gibt,
nennen ihn alle James.
* Telefonklingeln *
Guten Tag.
Hallo, James.
Du kannst die Seilbahn losschicken.
Dann schicke ich sie jetzt los.
Tschau, Seppi.
Allerdings hat James Odermatt
seit vielen Monaten Ärger.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die Bahn bleibt immer wieder stehen.
Was passiert jetzt?
Ist sie überladen?
Nein, sie muss wieder zurückfahren.
Dann geht es.
Nach etwa 80 m
schaltet sie sich automatisch aus.
Dann muss man rückwärts fahren
und im Schrank
die richtige Taste drücken.
Dann fährt sie wieder.
Die Technik
ist auch nicht mehr so ...
Es ist nötig, dass etwas passiert.
* Pfeifton *
Was ist jetzt los?
Anfangs, als sie noch nicht wussten,
dass sie rückwärts fahren müssen,
damit sie wieder funktioniert,
sassen wir mal
45 Min. in der Gondel.
Es ist einfach etwas mühsam,
wenn sich die Bahn ausschaltet
und Leute darin sitzen.
Diese erschrecken vielleicht,
fürchten sich
und wollen nicht mehr mitfahren,
weil sie denken,
die Sicherheit
sei nicht mehr gewährleistet.
Gefährlich ist die Störung nicht.
Aber James Odermatt
muss die Kabinen jedes Mal
zurück zum Startpunkt bringen.
Trotz grossem Aufwand finden auch
die Experten den Störungsgrund nicht.
Für alle ist klar:
Eine Sanierung ist dringend nötig.
Bei der Bergstation oben
in Wiesenberg wohnen 90 Personen.
Es gibt eine Bergwirtschaft ...
* Kirchenglocken *
... eine Kapelle ...
... und viele Bauernhöfe.
* Telefonklingeln *
Guten Morgen, James, hier ist Bruno.
Kann ich von Wiesenberg
in die Ledi fahren?
Gut, super.
Ich bin eingestiegen.
Du kannst losfahren.
Einen schönen Tag.
Tschau, James.
Bruno Niederberger
pendelt zwischen Alp und Hof,
schaut auf beiden Bauernbetrieben
zum Rechten.
Familie Niederberger
hat eine eigene Haltestelle.
Brunos Vorfahren bekamen
die Zwischenstation hier in der Ledi
als Entschädigung, als die Bahn
1934 auf ihrem Land gebaut wurde.
Die Bahn mit der Zwischenstation
ist hier, seit ich denken kann.
Als kleine Kinder kriegten wir mit,
wie unser Vater und der Grossvater
die Milch
mit der Bahn ins Tal schickten.
Sie war einfach allgegenwärtig.
Sie ist aus meinen Kopf
nicht wegzudenken.
Sie gehört zur Liegenschaft
wie das Haus oder die Scheune.
* Betätigen des Anlassers *
Sie hat für uns schon
eine ziemlich grosse Bedeutung.
* Er betätigt den Anlasser. *
* Starten des Motors *
Die Talstation in Dallenwil/NW.
Die Wiesenbergbahn ist ein kleines
Bähnchen im grossen Bahnland Schweiz,
eine von insgesamt 2'400 Seilbahnen
hierzulande.
Vom Tal geht es
in 8 Min. hoch nach Wiesenberg.
Die zwei Viererkabinen
befördern 16'000 Fahrgäste pro Jahr.
Eine Besonderheit: Unterwegs
gibt es drei Zwischenausstiege.
* Kirchenglocken *
Geht es aber
nach den ersten Sanierungsplänen,
fallen diese Zwischenausstiege weg.
Der Erhalt sei zu teuer.
Die Bahn würde nur noch
die Bergstation in Wiesenberg
mit der Talstation
in Dallenwil verbinden.
Diese Nachricht
hat Bruno Niederberger erschreckt.
Sein Hof Ledi ohne ÖV-Anschluss -
undenkbar.
* Entfernte Kirchenglocken *
Unsere Kinder fahren
tagtäglich mit der Bahn zur Schule.
Sie fahren hoch und runter.
Das ist
eine grosse Erleichterung für sie.
Hallo, Mama.
Super. Starten wir in die Ferien?
- Ja.
Gut.
Wenn ich
als Alpbewirtschafter ins Tal muss
und die Bahn hier nicht mehr hält,
fahre ich 1 Std. mit dem Auto.
Ansonsten bin ich in 15 Min. hier.
Das ist für mich
eine Zeitersparnis, die ...
... eigentlich nicht bezahlbar ist.
Ich sagte zum Vorstand:
"Abreissen geht schnell,
es später jedoch wieder aufzubauen,
ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit."
Wir versuchen
alles Menschenmögliche,
um das zusätzliche Geld
aufzutreiben,
damit wir Masten erhalten werden.
Das macht diese Bahn
meiner Meinung nach aus.
Aber wie soll der Genossenschafts-
vorstand das finanzieren?
Die Sanierung kostet 1 Mio. Fr.
Für die Zwischenstationen
kämen je 100'000 dazu.
Dabei kommt die kleine Bahn
schon jetzt kaum über die Runden.
James Odermatt
ist im Vorstand der Bahn.
Zusammen mit Josy Joller,
die für die Finanzen zuständig ist.
So ...
- Vielen Dank.
Du trinkst ihn schwarz, nicht wahr?
Ein Schlückchen Kaffeerahm
nehme ich gern.
Ich liess den Löffel noch drin.
Nächste Woche ist Vorstandssitzung.
Ich hoffe, du bist dabei?
- Ja.
Hunderttausende Franken
wird sie auftreiben müssen,
praktisch in Fronarbeit.
Für die Zwischenstationen
sieht sie schwarz.
Wir haben nicht so viel Geld,
um das auch noch aus
der Portokasse bezahlen zu können.
Die betroffenen Liegenschaften
haben eine Zufahrtsstrasse
und die Ausstiegstationen
wurden nicht mehr so häufig benutzt.
Natürlich sind sie praktisch -
z.B. für die Schulkinder
oder wenn man
zur Kapelle in Wiesenberg will.
Aber ich denke, es geht auch ohne.
Einen Zwischenausstieg
gibt es auch im Breitenacher.
Für Ruedi Durrer, der hier lebt,
ist die Bahn mit vielen
Kindheitserinnerungen verbunden.
Als wir zur Schule gingen,
mit sieben, acht Jahren,
trugen wir die Milch hierher
oder transportierten sie
mit einer Schubkarre.
Teils waren wir zu zweit und einer
von uns hielt die Milchkanne fest.
Wenn es nass war
und wir ausrutschten,
rollte die Milchkanne davon.
Wir mussten darauf achten,
dass der Deckel drauf blieb,
damit wir nichts verschütteten.
Zur Familie Durrer
gehört auch Marie, Ruedis Mutter.
Im Breitenacher gibt es eine ganze
Bahn-Mappe mit Erinnerungsstücken.
Hier sieht man
die alte, die erste Bahn.
Ein Abbruch des Zwischenausstiegs -
für Marie Durrer undenkbar.
Das gibt's nicht.
Dann bin ich eingesperrt.
Ich möchte so lange wie möglich
selbstständig sein,
selbst einkaufen gehen und
nicht auf Fremde angewiesen sein.
Denn zurzeit
geht es mir noch einigermassen gut.
Es wäre schön,
wenn ich hierbleiben könnte.
Ich wuchs nicht hier auf.
Ich bin eine Zugezogene.
Damals gab es
noch gar keine Strasse.
Alles musste mit der Bahn
hochtransportiert werden.
Es war anstrengend, aber man tat es.
Durch die Bahn hatte man etwas,
was andere Leute nicht hatten.
Schau, jetzt ...
- Die Bahn ist voll.
Vor etwa zehn Jahren
kriegten wir eine blaue Bahn.
Das ist der neue Mast -
zum Vergleich.
Für uns wird es
gewiss nicht möglich sein,
diese Zwischenstation
aufrechtzuerhalten.
Wir allein können das nicht stemmen.
Wir und die auf der Ledi
wären diejenigen,
die dafür aufkommen müssten.
Äh, ja ...
Ruedi Durrer ist selbst im Bahn-
Vorstand - eine verzwickte Situation.
Viel Zeit bleibt nicht.
Die Sanierung muss rasch kommen,
die Störungen häufen sich.
Einmal, zweimal, dreimal ...
... vier- oder fünfmal pro Tag.
* Er lacht. *
Hier ein-, zwei-,
drei-, vier-, fünfmal.
Die Bahn ist ein Stückwerk.
* Telefonklingeln *
Getriebe und Antriebsrad
haben Jahrgang '99,
das Rad '72,
das Gestell '36.
Die Einzelteile sind zwar in Ordnung,
aber zusammen mit der Steuerung
funktionieren sie nicht mehr.
Ich habe schon Angst davor,
dass sie plötzlich nicht mehr fährt.
Ein Totalausfall ist das Letzte,
was ich hoffe.
Das wäre
ein Horrorszenario für mich.
* Telefonklingeln *
Einmal pro Jahr trifft sich der
Vorstand der Seilbahngenossenschaft.
Traditionell
auf der Alp des Präsidenten.
Innen- oder aussenrum?
- Wir gehen innen rum.
Sonst wird alles schmutzig.
Es hat geregnet.
Ist es oben?
* Lachen *
Wie eine Kuh, die kalbt.
Ja.
Liebe Vorstandsmitglieder, ich
möchte das Wort an James übergeben.
Der Fehler, der jeweils auftritt -
ich klopfe auf Holz -,
trat seit dem letzten Dienstag
nicht mehr auf.
Ich hoffe, das bleibt so -
möglichst lange.
Das hört man gern.
Dann kommen wir
zum Traktandum Sanierungsprojekt.
Ein wesentlicher Punkt
betrifft ja die Zwischenausstiege.
Früher,
als es noch keine Strassen gab,
war ein Zwischenausstieg
eine Lebensader.
Heute ist es ein Luxus, den man
noch in Anspruch nehmen kann.
(Josy) Ja, mit Ruedi sitzt ja
ein direkt Betroffener am Tisch.
Man nimmt
den beiden Höfen etwas weg.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Es ist sicher ein angenehmer Luxus.
Es tut weh, ihn zu verlieren.
Die in der Ledi
sind wahrscheinlich diejenigen,
die ihn am meisten nutzen.
Gestern rief mich Bruno an
und fragte,
ob wir das
nicht nochmals überdenken könnten.
Für sie sei das
ein ziemlich grosser Einschnitt.
Angenommen,
wir sprechen von 1 Mio. Fr.
Dieses Geld zusammenzukriegen,
ist schwierig.
Wer ist damit einverstanden,
dass wir bei einer Sanierung
die drei Zwischenausstiege ...
... streichen?
Wer ist dafür?
Gut.
Wer ist dagegen?
Sechs sind dafür
und einer ist dagegen.
Wir werden sie also
nicht mehr berücksichtigen.
Für die weitere Planung.
- Für die weitere Planung, ja.
Dann beende ich die Sitzung hiermit.
Gut, danke.
Jetzt gehen wir alle runter
und kalbern? - Nein.
Ja, ich weiss,
dass du ein Kalb bist.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Eigentlich war es ja klar,
aber man kämpft bis zuletzt.
* Klingelton *
Könnte ich
vom Breitenacher ins Tal fahren?
Gut, danke.
Von der Talstation schickt
James Odermatt die Kabine 2 hoch.
* Pfeifton *
Während Marie Durrer
zum Einkaufen ins Dorf fährt ...
* Klopfendes Geräusch *
Bum, bum, bum.
* Beschwingte Klavierklänge *
... wartet weiter oben,
auf der Zwischenstation Ledi,
Familie Niederberger.
Während der Schulferien
fahren sie alle zusammen auf die Alp.
Trägst du die Tasche noch?
* Kinderlachen *
Zum Glück haben wir die Bahn. Sonst
müssten wir 1 Std. lang Auto fahren.
(Kind) 1 Std.?
Das ist der Vorteil der Bahn:
Wenn Mama zur Arbeit muss,
könnt ihr nach der Schule
alleine zu Daddy hochfahren.
Nicht wahr?
- Mhm.
Nicht nur die Bahn, auch die Strasse
zwischen Dallenwil und Wiesenberg
ist ein Sanierungsfall.
Sie wird ausgebaut und ist während
des Sommers tagsüber gesperrt.
Die Sanierung wird noch Jahre dauern.
Wer in dieser Zeit mit dem Auto
hoch nach Wiesenberg will,
fährt einen grossen Umweg.
Umso wichtiger
ist eine funktionstüchtige Bahn.
Das ist unbestritten.
Für die Zwischenstationen dagegen,
wie hier im Breitenacher,
kämpfen nur die Betroffenen.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir die einzigen
beiden betroffenen Parteien sind.
Es wird bestimmt nicht einfach,
für die Sache Stimmung zu machen.
Wir könnten eine jährliche
oder einmalige Entschädigung
verlangen oder sagen:
"Die Bahn ist uns lieb und recht."
"Wir wollen der Bahn
eigentlich keinen Ärger machen."
Von der Bergstation
geht es für Familie Niederberger
zu Fuss weiter auf die Alp.
20 Min. dauert der Marsch.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
* Lachen *
* Kuhglocken *
Komm, Florian.
(Bruno) Ihr kommt eh nicht rein,
ich habe den Schlüssel.
Die Bahnsanierung reisst einen Graben
auf in der kleinen Gemeinschaft.
Komm, komm.
(Bruno) Man wirft ja
nicht mit Steinen aufeinander
oder wünscht
den anderen etwas Schlechtes.
Die Fronten sind verhärtet,
aber wir sind nicht verkracht.
Wir sagen nicht: "Du hast mir
etwas zuleide getan oder ich dir."
Es ist einfach
eine normale Auseinandersetzung,
eine normale
Meinungsverschiedenheit,
die sein muss.
Komm, rein, komm.
* Lockender Pfiff *
Ganz so entspannt
sehen es nicht alle.
Hallo. Grüezi.
Zu dritt? Jawohl.
Um zehn nach fahre ich los.
Danke.
Ablösung in der Talstation.
James Odermatt übergibt den Betrieb
seinem Lebenspartner Werner.
Nochmals schliessen. Nochmals öffnen
und wieder schliessen.
Sechs Aushilfen hat James Odermatt.
Hast du schon
ein bisschen den Überblick?
Nein, das ist ... Den hast du.
- Ja.
Okay, schönen Abend.
Danke, gleichfalls.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wenn es ganz seltsam
oder speziell ist,
bin ich überfordert.
Ich bin ja nur ...
Ich bin James' Freund
und übernehme für ihn,
wenn er in die Kapelle geht oder so.
Ich bin nicht offiziell
bei der Bahn angestellt.
Jahrelang hat James Odermatt
oben in Wiesenberg
den Bauernbetrieb seiner Eltern
geführt,
bis ihn
eine asthmatische Krankheit bremste.
Erst dann, vor zehn Jahren,
wechselte er zur Bahn.
Eine Aufgabe aber
hat er noch immer in Wiesenberg:
Der Hof der Odermatts
gleich neben der Wiesenberger Kapelle
muss den Sigrist stellen.
Das ist in einem sog. Servitut
vertraglich festgelegt.
Als vor 50 Jahren mein Onkel starb,
hiess es:
"Das kannst du doch machen."
Daher bin ich
seit 50 Jahren Sigrist.
Mit 13 hat er das Amt übernommen.
Ich muss noch nichts machen.
Als James ein Bub war,
gab es in der Kapelle Wiesenberg
jeden Tag eine Messe.
Keinen Sonntag
konnte er einfach freimachen.
Über die Jahrzehnte
nahm die Zahl der Gottesdienste ab.
Heute gibt es noch einen wöchentlich.
Die Kapelle ist für ihn
wie eine zweite Wohnstube.
Hier erlebte ich Freud und Leid,
Schönes und Trauriges,
Sommer und Winter.
Ich finde es wirklich schön,
hier zu arbeiten.
* Kirchenglocken, sanfte Klänge *
Bald wird James Odermatt
nicht mehr direkt bei der Kapelle
aussteigen können.
Mit der Sanierung
wird auch diese Zwischenstation
geschlossen, so der Plan.
Betroffen wäre auch der Kaplan.
* Kirchenglocken *
Guten Abend.
Die jährliche Generalversammlung
der Seilbahngenossenschaft steht an.
Der Vorstand ist gefordert.
(Josy) Die Sache mit der Bahn
ist etwas schwierig.
Man kann nicht einfach
eine Grube ausheben,
wie wenn man ein Gartenhäuschen
bauen würde,
ein paar Latten zusammennageln
und danach dort grillieren.
Man benötigt Bewilligungen
und die Gesetze ändern sich dauernd.
Ich bin immer etwas nervös -
jedes Mal.
Oder dort drüben?
- Ja.- Unter dem Dach.
Der Vorstand hat gute Neuigkeiten:
Die Zwischenausstiege
sind doch noch nicht ganz vom Tisch.
Liebe Genossenschafterinnen
und Genossenschafter ...
So hört man es, oder?
- Es ist Ende August 2021.
Liebe Genossenschafterinnen
und Genossenschafter,
ich übergebe das Wort
an Josy Joller.
Für die dringend notwendigen
Sanierungsmassnahmen
rechnen wir mit Kosten
in der Höhe von 1 Mio. Fr.
Nebst den Eigenmitteln,
die hoffentlich zwei Drittel
der Gesamtkosten ausmachen werden,
bleiben noch rund 300'000 Fr. übrig,
die wir auf anderem Weg
beschaffen müssen.
Werden die Ausstiege auch in Zukunft
wieder vorhanden sein?
Da das insgesamt Kosten
von rund 300'000 Fr. verursacht,
werden wir einen Kredit beantragen,
in dem die Ausstiege
nicht einberechnet sind.
Wir werden
im Rahmen des Projekts prüfen,
ob es möglich ist, die Ausstiege
nachträglich hinzuzufügen.
Hat noch jemand Fragen
zur Finanzierung?
Ja?
Vielleicht gibt es ja jemanden,
der die beiden Einstiegsstellen
erhalten möchte
und das nötige Kleingeld
aufbringen kann.
Wir brauchen nur jemanden
mit einem guten Portemonnaie.
* Alle lachen. *
Geschätzte Anwesende,
ich empfehle Ihnen,
an die Patenschaft für Berggemeinden
zu schreiben.
Hans-Ruedi Merz, ein lieber Kamerad
von mir, ist der Vorsitzende.
Ich werde persönlich
mit ihm sprechen.
Wir haben das auch schon geprüft.
Man darf nur bei einer solchen
Organisation ein Gesuch stellen.
Wir entschieden uns für ein Gesuch
bei der Schweizer Berghilfe.
Aber ich prüfe das
auf jeden Fall nochmals.
Die Patenschaft Berggemeinden
hat relativ viel Geld.
Pro Jahr
werden ca. 25 Mio. vergeben.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Kaliber
als die Berghilfe.
* Lachen im Saal *
Gut. Dann stimmen wir ab.
Vielen Dank. Der Antrag wurde ...
... einstimmig - das kann man
so sagen, nicht wahr? - angenommen.
Der grosse Sanierungskredit ist
genehmigt - ohne Zwischenstationen.
Aber immerhin
will der Vorstand klären,
ob die Ausstiege nachträglich
wieder in Betrieb gehen könnten.
Geschafft.
Es ist gut gelaufen.
Findest du nicht?
Ja, sehr.
Das macht einem Mut.
Die Leute wollen die Bahn.
Sie unterstützen das Ganze.
Hallo.
- Sali.
Ruedi Durrers Nachbar
Bruno Niederberger
ist nicht Genossenschafter.
(Ruedi) Aber er wird
nun draussen sein.
Guten Tag.
- Es sieht gut aus, Bruno.
Ich glaube, es sieht gut aus.
Ich denke, jetzt wird alles gut.
Aber ... Nein, es wird alles gut.
- Das hoffe ich auch.
Wir kämpfen weiter.
- Ja.
Ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass sie noch hinzugefügt werden.
Sind Sie auch zufrieden?
Ja, wenn es so bleibt, schon.
Wenn es so bleibt ...
Es liegt Hoffnung in der Luft
an diesem Abend.
* Perlende Klänge *
Wiesenberg feiert heute Chilbi,
Chilbi mit Freiluft-Gottesdienst.
Was musst du
für die Messe vorbereiten?
Wir müssen die Bänke ...
... und den Altar ...
... und alles andere,
was benötigt wird, hochtragen.
Der Alpenhof,
etwas oberhalb der Bergstation.
Ab Mittag wird die Gaststube
zum Zentrum des Fests.
Die zweitunterste Schublade, aber du
kannst sie in der Mikrowelle öffnen.
Der kleine Kilian Gisler
ist zum ersten Mal dabei.
Seine Mutter Janine Gisler wohnt
seit fünf Jahren im Alpenhof.
Sie will
Vorstandsmitglied der Bahn werden.
Jetzt muss Mama dann wieder spielen.
Das Bahn-Fieber hat
die Berner Oberländerin angesteckt.
Die Bahn ist
eigentlich unser ÖV-Anschluss.
Hier oben auf dem Berg
gibt es keinen Zug
und auch keine Busverbindungen.
Dank der Bahn
haben wir eine gewisse Autonomie.
Auch für die Schulkinder
ist sie wichtig.
Mein Kleiner
geht noch nicht zur Schule,
aber irgendwann
wird er zur Schule müssen.
So lernen sie ziemlich früh,
selbstständig zu werden.
Denn sie müssen die Bahn
beim Einstieg ja selbst bedienen
und die Talstation anrufen.
Irgendwie ist es auch cool,
wenn er mit der Bahn
zur Schule fahren kann.
In Gislers Wohnstube im ersten Stock
wärmt sich der berühmte Wiesenberger
Jodlerchor für die Chilbi auf.
* Lachen *
* Mehrstimmiger Jodel *
Janines Mann Florian jodelt mit.
Für wen?
- Für dich und für Urs.
Soll ich noch etwas
in den Kühlschrank stellen?- Ja.
* Jemand jodelt. *
* Mehrere stimmen mit ein. *
Nochmals. Wisst ihr noch,
wann ihr stoppen müsst?
* Mehrstimmiger, inbrünstiger Jodel *
Der Chor
gehört zu Wiesenberg wie die Bahn.
(Janine) Sie hat hier
schon Kultstatus.
Der Kanton Nidwalden ist ja all-
gemein für kleine Bähnchen bekannt.
Für diejenigen, die schon sehr lange
hier wohnen und hier aufwuchsen,
hat die Bahn schon
auch eine emotionale Bedeutung.
* Mehrstimmiger Jodel *
In 5 Min. ist man von der Bergstation
zu Fuss in der Kapelle.
* Kirchenglocken, Lachen *
Herr, erbarme dich.
(Alle) Herr, erbarme dich.
# (Im Chor) Heilig isch der Herr.
# Heilig isch der Herr.
* Muntere Volksmusik
aus dem Hintergrund *
In der Küche krampfen derweil
die Eltern Gisler, Helen und Sepp.
* Muntere Volksmusik *
Egal welche Generation,
hier hat jede und jeder
eine Geschichte mit der Bahn.
Sali, Götti.
Wenn wir ausgingen,
war die Bahn jeweils auch wichtig.
V.a., wenn wir morgens
nach Hause wollten.
Wenn wir nicht mehr fahren durften,
nahmen wir die Bahn.
Einmal stieg ich unten ein und
als ich das nächste Mal erwachte,
war ich fast wieder unten.
* Lachen *
Mein Vater ist ja Briefträger.
Beim zweiten Mal wartete er oben
und sorgte dafür,
dass ich aussteige.
* Muntere Volksmusik *
Ein paar Wochen später ist klar:
Die Zwischenausstiege lassen sich
auch nachträglich nicht mehr machen.
Der Hoffnungsschimmer der letzten GV
ist verschwunden.
Die Stützen müssten viel stärker
gesichert werden als heute.
Die Auflagen sind nicht abzuschätzen.
Eine Delegation
muss die Nachricht überbringen.
Neben den Vorstandsmitgliedern dabei
auch Patrick Enz von der Seilbahn-
firma Von Rotz & Wiedemar.
Er hat das Fachwissen
in die Diskussion gebracht.
* Metallisches Knarrgeräusch*
Erste Station: Breitenacher.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Ich muss immer auf die Notizen
schauen, sonst geht das nicht.
Ich begrüsse euch herzlich
bei Familie Durrer.
Irgendwie kamen wir zum Schluss,
dass es einfach nicht geht.
Technisch wäre es machbar,
finanziell sehr schwierig
und rechtlich
und bewilligungstechnisch
zurzeit unabwägbar.
Dazu muss ich einfach sagen,
dass wir eine Servitut
auf der Zwischenstation
im Breitenacher haben.
Darin steht, dass die Zwischen-
station betrieben werden muss,
solange die Bahn betrieben wird.
Nun stellt sich die Frage,
was jetzt geschieht.
Was nützt mir die Bahn, wenn ich
die Zwischenstation nicht mehr habe?
Ich will der Bahn nicht
im Weg stehen. Das will ich nicht.
Aber das sind einfach
meine Gedankengänge.
Wir sind ein bisschen
in einer Zwickmühle.
Das sind wir schon lange.
Die Männer müssen weiter.
Sie wissen: Bei Durrers Nachbar Bruno
Niederberger wird es schwieriger.
Jetzt sind wir
schon etwas warm, was?
Ja, jetzt wissen wir schon, wie ...
Es ist dasselbe Spiel.
Nicht ganz dasselbe, aber ...
Eine härtere Nuss.
- Es ist nicht ganz dasselbe.
Zum Glück ist Josy nicht dabei.
Ich spüre sie im Genick.
Du spürst sie?
Man muss hart bleiben.
Man muss hart bleiben
und nicht wieder sagen:
"Ja, ja, gut,
wir prüfen es nochmals."
Ja, es ist schwierig.
* Hundebellen,
spannungsvolle Klänge *
Sali.
* Hundebellen *
Sie kommen gleich.
Hallo. Bruno.
- Niklaus.
Bruno.
- Sali. - Sali.
Danke.
- Bitte.
Wir sind heute zusammengekommen,
um den Entscheid, die
drei Zwischenausstiege zu streichen,
zu erklären und zu begründen.
Das Problem
ist eigentlich Folgendes:
Wenn wir es
zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt machen,
wird es nicht mehr als Umbau,
sondern als Neubau betrachtet.
Ein Neubauprojekt
nach der Sanierung,
um die Zwischenstationen
wieder aufzubauen?
Das ist viel zu aufwendig und teuer.
Aber Bruno Niederberger
will es nicht akzeptieren.
Die Diskussion dreht sich weiter
um die 200'000 Fr. Zusatzkosten
für die Zwischenausstiege.
200'000 Fr. im Vergleich
zu 1 Mio. Fr. sind nicht viel.
Nein, absolut nicht.
Daran gibt's nichts zu rütteln.
200'000 mehr. Das ist meine Meinung.
Ich bin sicher,
alle hätten zugestimmt,
wenn an der Generalversammlung
1,5 Mio. beantragt worden wären.
Es geht hier um meine Kinder ...
- Das verstehe ich.
... und um dieses Gebiet,
das so gut erschlossen wäre.
Auf den Wegen hier hinten
wandern viele Leute.
Für uns ist das schon
sehr emotional, wirklich.
Dieses ganze Projekt.
- Ja, das verstehe ich.
Der Aufwand, um einen Zwischen-
ausstieg, wie er hier vorhanden ist,
öffentlich zu machen,
ist unverhältnismässig.
Der Aufwand ist nicht klar.
Er ist zurzeit
nicht genau definierbar.
Ich könnte noch
zwei Kontakte spielen lassen.
Es gibt so viele Menschen
auf dieser Welt,
die Geld im Überschuss haben.
Es gibt nirgends
so viele wie in der Schweiz,
die für Unnützes
dumm und dämlich Geld ausgeben.
Was heisst das?
Wann kannst du diese Anrufe tätigen?
Ich kann ihn morgen anrufen.
- Gut, ich gebe dir die Karte.
Man kann mich
unter dieser Nummer anrufen.
Ich rufe ihn morgen an.
Er kann mich
auch am Wochenende anrufen.
Gut.
Die Vorstandsmitglieder
wollten hart bleiben.
Stattdessen liessen sie
wieder Hoffnung aufkommen.
Wir sind eingestiegen.
Gut, tschau, James.
Aber die Woche verstreicht.
Es sind keine Geldgeber zu finden.
Bruno Niederberger kann
die Zwischenstation nicht retten.
Sie können einsteigen.
Ich komme gleich raus.
- Gut.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Die Bahn macht mittlerweile,
was sie will.
Die Störung, dass sich die Bahn
ausschaltet, wenn man losfährt,
trat schon länger nicht mehr auf,
aber dafür gibt es
teils andere Störungen.
Es kam etwa zwei- bis dreimal vor,
dass ich Zwischenstationen
anfahren wollte,
um Leute ein- oder auszuladen,
und dass die Bahn
einfach vorbeifuhr.
Es ist Ende 2021.
Die Spenden lassen auf sich warten.
Das Projekt wird kontinuierlich
teurer. Die Kassierin kämpft.
Es fehlen schon noch
etwa 300'000-400'000 Fr.
Aber einige Gesuche sind noch offen
und wir hoffen
auf gute Rückmeldungen.
Als Laie ist man manchmal
etwas hilflos, muss ich sagen.
Wir machten
zwei, drei Schritte vorwärts
und einen oder zwei Schritte
rückwärts.
Es ist schon ziemlich schwierig,
das Ganze zu bewältigen.
Ich hoffe, dass die Bahn
noch so lange wie möglich fährt
und dass es keine grösseren Ausfälle
oder Schäden gibt,
sodass wir den Betrieb
einstellen müssen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Seine Lieblingsjahreszeit aber lässt
sich James Odermatt nicht verderben.
In den letzten acht Jahren habe ich
mich allein darum gekümmert.
Manchmal helfen noch Firmlinge mit,
aber dieses Jahr hat sich
anscheinend niemand angemeldet.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Im Mai 2022 steht wieder eine GV an.
Liebe Genossenschafter/-innen,
herzlich willkommen
hier im Alpenhof in Wiesenberg.
Nach fast einem Jahr
störungsfreiem Betrieb
muckt die Wiesenbergbahn
seit einiger Zeit teils wieder auf.
Sie ist gestört.
* Alle lachen. *
Mein Vorstandskollege
Niklaus Reinhard
sagte vor Kurzem:
"Sie hat halt Charakter."
Dieser Charakter
kommt uns jetzt teuer zu stehen.
(Niklaus)
Wir sprechen jetzt von 1,2 Mio. Fr.
Wir sind sicher, dass wir die Bahn
mit diesen 1,2 Mio. Fr.
sanieren können.
Nun noch der grösste Clou:
die Schweizer Patenschaft
für Berggemeinden.
An der letzten Generalversammlung
im August
gab uns Hansueli Schneider den Tipp,
bei der Schweizer Patenschaft
für Berggemeinden
ein Gesuch einzureichen.
Das taten wir.
Sie sicherten uns eine Spende von
sage und schreibe 250'000 Fr. zu.
Die Sanierung ist auf guten Wegen.
Für den Vorstand
Zeit für eine Erneuerung.
Wir schlagen euch
folgende Personen zur Wahl vor:
Janine Gisler, Alpenhof Wiesenberg.
Ist Janine in der Nähe?
Dann wisst ihr gleich ...
Janine ist mit
Florian vom Alpenhof verheiratet.
Sie haben einen gemeinsamen Sohn,
Kilian,
und ihr zweites Kind ist unterwegs.
* Lachen *
Das hätte ich nicht sagen müssen,
nicht wahr?
* Lachen *
Jedem das Seine.
Das war mir jetzt etwas peinlich.
* Lachen *
Noch sieben Monate fährt die
Wiesenbergbahn pannenanfällig weiter.
Erst im Januar 2023
startet endlich die Sanierung.
Die globalen Lieferengpässe
haben sich bis
in den Kanton Nidwalden ausgewirkt.
Der Zeitplan ist eng.
Die Bahn
muss wieder in Betrieb gehen,
bevor die Strasse am 1. Mai
wie jedes Jahr geschlossen wird.
(Josy) Ich bin
bis jetzt sehr zufrieden.
Ich atmete erst auf, als es
vor zwei, drei Wochen losging.
Inzwischen schlafe ich etwas besser.
Wir erhielten sehr viele Spenden.
Vielen Dank und bis später.
Tschüss, Martha.
Das hatten wir nicht erwartet.
Darüber sind wir
natürlich total glücklich.
Ohne Spenden
wäre es schon schwierig geworden.
Allein
bei der Patenschaft Berggemeinden
haben sich die Spenden
inzwischen verdoppelt.
Waren es an der letzten GV
noch 250'000 Fr.,
sind es mittlerweile fast 500'000.
Was die Zwischenstationen betrifft,
nützt der Geldsegen aber nichts mehr.
Sie lassen sich nicht
ins laufende Projekt einfügen.
Es bräuchte
ein neues Bewilligungsverfahren.
Ja ...
- Nun ist es halt so.
Eine Ära ist vorüber.
Ja ... und ...
Schade.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Technisch wird es anders sein,
eher computer...
...gesteuert.
Man wird keine Knöpfe
mehr drücken müssen,
sondern man wird streicheln.
Touchdream, Touchstream,
oder wie man das nennt.
In der Ledi hat Bruno Niederberger
den Abbruch der Zwischenstation
verpasst.
Er arbeitet im Winter
auswärts als Gipser.
Kam der Helikopter?
Ja, er war nahe beim Haus.
- Wirklich? - Ja.
(Bruno) Das hier unten? Ja.
Ja, jetzt ist sie weg.
Sie war seit 1933 hier.
Ja.
Erst in den letzten Tagen
hat er entdeckt,
dass der Anspruch
auf eine Zwischenstation
im Grundbuch festgehalten ist.
Das sind die Verträge.
Ein Durchleitungsvertrag.
Die Bahn
darf nur über das Land fahren,
wenn ein Ein- und Ausstieg
geboten wird.
Unsere Rechtschutzversicherung
soll das prüfen.
Sie soll prüfen,
ob das Hand und Fuss hat.
Ich bin kein Jurist.
Wenn sie diesen Mast
schon streichen,
kriegen wir vielleicht 2, 3 Fr.
Etwas an die Unkosten,
die wir jetzt haben.
Neuer Lack für die alten Gondeln.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist jetzt die neue Steuerung.
Man muss hier
die "Bereit"-Taste drücken
und so kann man
die Geschwindigkeit reduzieren.
Ich glaube,
ich kriege sie wieder in Gang.
* Sanfte Alphornmusik *
Die Wiesenbergbahn
fährt jetzt an der Kapelle vorbei.
Der Ausstieg ist gesperrt.
Die Bahn ist für mich
ein Bild für den Weg ans Licht.
Dort,
wo für uns vielleicht Gott ist.
* Sanfte Alphornklänge *
Wir bitten um den Segen für die Bahn
als Ganzes und für die Kabine.
Wir bitten um deinen Segen
für diese Masten.
Im Namen des Vaters,
des Sohnes und des Heiligen Geistes.
Amen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das Millionenprojekt
ist abgeschlossen.
Ein Erfolg für die Verantwortlichen.
Mit dem Abbruch der Zwischenstationen
sind sie im Reinen.
(Josy) Ich denke schon,
dass wir das Richtige getan haben.
Ich glaube, das wäre langfristig
zu einer grossen Belastung
für die Bahn geworden.
Die Unterhaltskosten
und die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
wären enorm gewesen.
Im Nachhinein kann man sagen,
dass es vielleicht gereicht hätte.
Das kann sein.
Aber es wären schon
Zusatzkosten gewesen.
In dem Moment,
in dem wir entscheiden mussten,
war das Geld
halt noch nicht vorhanden.
Es war alles ungewiss.
* Glockenläuten, sanfte Klänge *
Während der Einweihung
ist Bruno Niederberger auf der Alp.
Mit dem neuen Vorstandspräsidenten
der Bahn versteht er sich gut,
trotz der komplizierten Situation.
Wir hatten
sehr gute Gespräche mit ihm.
Es hängt davon ab,
inwiefern sie uns entgegenkommen.
Sie würden uns eine Entschädigung
von ungefähr 100 Fr. pro Jahr
bezahlen
und wir fordern eine Entschädigung
von etwa 1'500 Fr.
Wenn sie uns keinen
sehr grossen Schritt entgegenkommen,
haben wir mit der
Rechtschutzversicherung vereinbart,
dass wir versuchen,
das Maximum rauszuholen.
Man sah die Notlage der Bahn,
wollte möglichst schnell
etwas dagegen unternehmen
und prüfte das Ganze
nicht sorgfältig.
Meiner Meinung nach
war die Entscheidung überstürzt.
Die Bahn fährt jetzt pannenfrei.
Aber der Graben,
den die Sanierung aufgerissen hat,
ist noch nicht zugeschüttet.
Hier habe ich die Bilder
aller Überwachungskameras.
So sehe ich,
ob unten oder oben jemand ist.
Das ist ziemlich praktisch.
Ich habe mich verklickt.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht mehr weiter.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2023